the heretic in the modern secular nation
state has been replaced by the ethnic
minority
very often these Heretics were not they
didn't have uh theological differences
uh they they were mostly especially in
Europe they were protesting against uh
the the the in the structural Injustice
that was emerging there and and
therefore they're cut down uh Henry VII
and Elizabeth all persecuted uh
Catholics because they were treaters to
the state why why were they conceived of
Australia because the state was
developing uh sovereign powers and in
the Primo before the early modern period
the ruling class expected to have a
different religion from the masses yes
but but it still doesn't get you around
the fact that they're only they're only
uh act traitorous action is to believe
something different no it isn't no no no
no it isn't uh it really is not most
people well to owe their allegiance as
it were to a different Authority let's
have a look at the sunny Shia thing
that's not about Doctrine at all
uh there's virtually no theological
difference between the Sunni and the
Shia it begins as a profound political
uh uh dispute as to who should lead the
Muslim Uma it's about lineage isn't it
and and it's not just about lineage it's
about Justice
and you have the the complication that
the Muslims were developing an Empire an
empire was considered strange as it may
seem to us to have been the uh the best
way of keeping the peace because it
meant that you have a supreme power that
is able to uh hold warring aristocracies
in Czech and the Muslims had to do this
but this was utterly against the
egalitarianism of the Quran and so there
were people not just sufis to uh
philosophers to all protesting against
against this and the Shia is is is a
piety of protest of disciplined protest
against the Injustice of mainstream
Muslim Society you do you make a very
good case I think that
um if you're to if you were to make the
case that religion is inherently violent
you have to selectively quote because
every single scriptural tradition will
have a contradiction we are violent
creatures we are for us therefore our
scriptures can I just ask you something
about uh that distinction between as it
were the moral and ethical components of
all the major religions
and the elements that repeatedly in
history cause
violence and cause cause you know
violent conflict and it's supernatural
belief
um I wondered from your knowledge of
History has there ever been a violent
doctrinal dispute over what it means to
be generous to the poor saying
uh well actually most of the
I mentioned in the book in Europe were
protesting against the the aristocracy
who were at that point creating a
full-blown uh Empire uh so there is so
then there's a yes and then the
Buddhists uh the confucians are very
much about the Golden Rule and they are
creating throughout the major theme in
this book has been the constant attempt
to create alternatives to the violence
of the state in the Buddhist Sangha uh
deliberately designed in many ways to um
to sort of challenge the aggressive
ethos of the Court yoga is very much
about getting rid of the aggression
um and and then
in the mind uh the egotistic me first
drive that makes us love fighting and
comforting even verbally and then uh you
have and then the Buddha sends them out
to work for the good and Welfare of of
humanity uh the uh the prophet Muhammad
the Quran the Quran is an outcry against
the structural Injustice that is
emerging in capitalist Mecca
so uh and my favorite story and I told
you to you the other the morning uh is
is Ashoka
first a third Century Emperor BCE in
India
who I was a cruel man he came to power
uh by killing two of his brothers
um but he went on he accompanied the
Army when it when it was putting down a
rebellious City and he was appalled by
the violence that he saw he was
horrified by seeing all these peasants
uh being carted off away from their
families to Work Land elsewhere in the
Empire and he put up throughout his
domains uh inscriptions on huge Rock
faces and massive cylindrical pillars
that were uncovered in the 19th century
calling out for justice for kindness to
the poor for tolerance for recognizing
and that all sects were equally valid
all teachers must be listened to not
even those deemed heretical by the
brahmians uh this is uh uh and he is
going to create clinics for the poor he
is going to put up shade trees for the
refreshment of animals and humans alike
but he can never disband his army and he
cannot send back repatriate all those
peasants that he's uprooted because they
are essential to The Agrarian economy
now this is the Dilemma of civilization
and that's why these people say
scornfully well you know these people
like Buddhists they were never able to
succeed uh that is that but they kept up
this uh this this alternative Vision
this alternative outcry
um and that's what we must do now in our
secular World create mythologies just as
they did in the uh in the best of the
scriptures
uh right from ancient Mesopotamia that
made the people aware told stories and
bits that made people aware of the
profound Injustice and violence that was
being done to the poor and The Peasants
can I ask why you think the mythology is
necessary rather than just the Golden
Rule the golden rule is absolutely fine
um I I think if we could just all do
that and in whatever we did and any Walk
of Life that we happen to find ourselves
in everything all day and every day not
just when we feel like it you know I've
done well that's my good deed for the
day uh though all day and every day
that's what Confucius said then I think
we'd have a peaceful world and if we but
but the thing about the golden rule is
the Golden Rule will never will never
license an act of violence
a belief in a supernatural God can and
has done repeatedly but we have a very
very uh primitive view in the modern
world of what we mean by the
supernatural
um to be honest I mean Thomas Aquinas
and uh Meister Eckhart would have been
turning in their graves
um if they could hear the way we speak
about a supernatural God it's this is
again one of the unique things that we
we developed with our scientific uh
again wouldn't that be precisely one of
the arraignments against religion is
that of course there would be no problem
if we were all theology Scholars
that's why you need mythology because a
myth we you see this is one of the words
that has been absolutely degraded in our
modern ethos a myth is something that
isn't true we say a politician if asked
accused of a peccadillo in his past life
will say oh it's a myth it didn't happen
uh in fact a myth and I've written a
whole book on this uh um uh I'm not
going to quarrel with you your
definition a myth is uh some it tells a
story of something that in some sense
happened once but which also happens all
the time it is uncovering a Timeless
truth that we uh that that goes beneath
uh everyday perceptions but that lies at
the heart of the reality as we see it
but does it inner guise that uh that
makes it accessible to people
furthermore a myth makes absolutely no
sense unless it is put into practice
it's a program for Action so when you
read the myths of Greek and Rome for
example it's not going to hit the solar
plexus but when a myth is translated is
Made Alive brought alive say in a ritual
or is in an ethical practice that is
incarnated in a person's life then you
discover the truth of the myth but it's
no good looking at these myths uh uh and
saying well it it this this doesn't work
a myth is a call for practical action
and unless you do it you don't get it
could we phrase this slightly
differently then in a way we can
probably both agree which is the problem
isn't religion it's religious people or
rather
to make it
as it were completely uncontentious the
problem is people who are absolutely
certain that they are right
I well there are plenty of secular
politicians
I was expanding the definition to bring
them in uh who I think they're
absolutely right I I think the problem
is with us all never mind religious
secular or religious look have how have
things got greatly better since we
chucked religion out of politics
um do is there less unkindness less
cruelty less uh unsusions about the sub
the poor uh are we uh do we just not
just retire to uh comfortable homes and
and say I don't want us I don't want to
see this news about that earthquake or
this particular catastrophe here uh the
the Muslims scholar in Lebanon and then
in the 1980s accused the west of
maintaining an arrogant silence in face
of the third world so
um it I I think the problem is with all
of us we are all violent people all
deeply selfish people uh we uh we love
to hate people because it makes us feel
good I call my book on compassion 12
steps to a compassionate life because we
are addicted to our pet hatreds we don't
know what we do without them we depend
upon them for our sense of self